добрый вечер это стив я хочу
разговаривать разговаривать с вами через
google пас я хочу поговорить
обсудить обсудить
объяснить новую версию
ликов особенности страницу урок это я
буду сделать
понедельник 3 декабря в девять часов
вечера по московскому времени
надеюсь что вы будете принять участие в
этой дискуссии мы используем систем
google класс потому что это очень
удобный чтобы принять участ
вы должны идти к странице
link в google plus а там вы должны
следовать
на это странице следовать над нами и я
буду пригласить всех людей которые там
будут следовать на данном во время нашей
дискуссии наше обсуждение гурт вас могут
принять участь
это означает что будет появляться на
экране только я и 9 человек
но другие друзей могут посмотреть потому
что это будет транслироваться через
youtube и вы можете тоже послаще
комментарий или давать вопросе и я буду
попробовать ответить на эти вопросы
хорошо но надеюсь что в понедельник 3
декабря 9 часов московскому времени вы
будете со мной в губы паз до встречи до
свидания и спасибо